breaking news crypto play turned out to
be a big scam in other news the sky is
blue and those clouds in Congress did it
again what a bunch of clowns
how does he keep up with the news like
that last week FTX the second largest
cryptocurrency Exchange in the world
filed for bankruptcy and it's FTX it's a
safe and easy way to get into crypto
yeah
2022 was a
was ever for cryptocurrency but even in
this volatile Market FCX sudden
implosion took people by in Surprise
many Saw FTX as the squeaky clean white
knight in the crypto world but with FTX
and bankruptcy tens of billions of
dollars AKA real money missing and giant
holes in the balance sheet there's going
to be hell to pay which is why lawyers
are the real white Knights so what did
FTX do wrong what laws might they have
broken and who was going to jail or
maybe it would be easier to talk about
who's not going to jail but hold on
folks we have a lot of ground to cover
because there were probably a lot of
crimes broken FTX had over a million
users and was recently valued at 32
billion dollars company was founded in
2019 by Sam bankman freed a 30 year old
ostensible Wonder kid Beckman freed
garnered lots of attention for having a
romantic relationship with 10 other
crypto people and playing League of
Legends during meetings which apparently
was a sign of genius and business Acumen
and if so I guess I need to give my
intern a raise but those warning signs
didn't stop him from securing massive
investments from some of the biggest
funders in Silicon Valley if anything it
helped him procure that funding
foreshadowing but Bayman freed became
the darling of the crypto industry
swooping in to rescue Robin Hood and
Voyager digital when they were
struggling earlier this year and
donating millions of dollars to the
Democratic party and now surprising no
one block Phi which was rescued by FTX
is now going bankrupt as well Sam
bankman freed or SPF as he was known got
his start at Jane Street a quantitative
trading firm that focused on Arbitrage
opportunities in Capital Market flows
after that he started a hedge fund
called Alameda research in 2017. benkman
freed made his first Fortune by
capitalizing on an Arbitrage opportunity
where he could buy crypto coins at low
prices in the U.S and sell them at a
much higher price in Japan and in 2019
bankman freed started FTX a crypto
exchange which set out to accommodate
the kind of trading that he was doing at
Alameda The Exchange made fees on the
buying and selling of different assets
some of which are illegal in U.S because
they were too risky again more
foreshadowing but that's one of the
reasons why FTX and other companies were
Incorporated in the Bahamas and FTX and
Alameda also spawned a host of sister
companies that are involved in the bank
now FTX became the second or third
largest crypto exchange by volume and
often became the lender of Last Resort
in many failed crypto projects some
called bankman freed the JP Morgan of
the crypto World echoing the way that
Morgan Had scooped up assets at low
prices and bankman freed often suggested
that he was going to buy Goldman Sachs
at one point alas that day is never
going to come because reports now say
that Bang been freed may have improperly
transferred 10 billion dollars in
customer money to his hedge fund Alameda
research and that at least one billion
dollars of that money is missing hackers
made off with over 400 million dollars
in tokens some speculate that this might
have been an inside job and two weeks
ago the company said that its tokens
were worth about 5.5 billion dollars but
the real value may have been only in the
hundreds of Millions with less than one
million dollars in liquid assets bankman
freed was worth 30 billion dollars at
one point but lost at least 94 percent
of that as it was wiped out in a single
day and all this has Regulators courts
and lawyers circling ftx's corpse so
there's already lawsuits and it's
possible people that everyone is going
to jail and part of the reason is that
bankman freed allegedly started moving
or lending billions of dollars from FTX
customer money to Alameda research which
suffered big losses through risky trades
Alameda put up FTX tokens known as ftt
as collateral for the loans this turned
out to be problematic because FTX tokens
weren't widely traded outside of FTX and
were highly correlated with the success
or failure of FTX itself now we'll talk
about this more in a second but this is
part of the magic beans problem that's
inherent in a lot of different crypto
projects throughout the entire industry
and recently FTX ran into financial
problems and started shopping around for
Investments Beckman freed sent investors
a term sheet that was a complete mess
according to investors who reviewed the
pitch quote it contained hastily
arranged balance sheets mostly in
unformatted Excel spreadsheets that were
replete with unformatted typos and
unnamed Pages like sheet number three no
advisors or standard information was
included and because of the sloppy
nature of the balance sheet the data
itself was questionable the balance
sheets showed that a lot of alameda's
assets consisted of ftt which is the
same name as ftx's tokens this meant
that the tokens were much less valuable
than previously thought Matt Levine of
Bloomberg explains why this is
especially notable quote the main
attribute is that FTX periodically uses
a portion of its profits to buy back ftt
tokens this makes ftt kind of like stock
in FTX the higher ftx's profits are the
higher the price of ftt will be and as
one Twitter user summarized it quote I
created a billion shares for my house
and sold one to my wife for one dollar
valuing my house at one billion dollars
give me 500 million dollars please now
throughout this whole Affair fts's main
competitor was binance it's CEO Chung
Pung Zhao started talking trash about
ftt on Twitter saying quote as part of
binance's exit from FTX Equity last year
binance received roughly 2.1 billion
dollars USD equivalent in cash busd and
ftt due to recent Revelations that have
come to light we've decided to liquidate
any remaining ftt on our books now the
FTC tokens were also the main liquid
asset FTX had to sell to pay user is
making withdrawals so if a bunch of
people lost faith in FTX and wanted to
take all their money out it would have
to sell its own cryptocurrency to get
the money and if people don't have faith
in your crypto exchange they probably
don't have faith in your cryptocurrency
either so it might not be worth enough
to pay them back and as a result FTX
crashed upon zhao's announcement that he
was selling all of binance's ftt causing
the coin's value to plummet then there
was a bank run or a crypto exchange run
in which retail investors sought to
withdraw their funds at the same time
though in the aftermath binance offered
to buy FTX International as sort of a
bailout though binance later pulled out
of the purchase solidifying the fact
that FTX was Belly Up This set off a
chain reaction as the rest of FTX users
tried to pull their money out but FDX
didn't have their money or to the extent
that it had made Investments those
Investments were illiquid and bankman
freed announced on Twitter that it would
be halting non-fiat withdrawals Days
Later FTX Alameda and its Associated
companies filed for chapter 11
bankruptcy now chapter 11 bankruptcy is
sometimes called a reorganization
bankruptcy and FTX is Bank is
complicated because it includes dozens
of related entities and shell companies
over 20 FTX companies have bankruptcy
petitions so far including Alameda
research the FTX entities filed slap
Dash bankruptcy petitions asking the
court to impose an automatic stay
against the collection of any
outstanding debts but the picture got a
little clear when FTX filed a motion
asking if it could file a list of its 50
biggest creditors by Friday and the
motion FTX said it could have up to a
million creditors probably mostly retail
people it said quote as set forth in the
debtor's petitions there are over 100
000 creditors in these chapter 11 cases
in fact there could be more than one
million creditors many of these
creditors will be FTX customers in other
bankruptcy cases involving crypto
customers have been designated as
unsecured creditors which means they
will be last in line for any repayment
now two days after the bankruptcy
petitions FTX appointed new CEO to see
the companies through bankruptcy John
Ray Ray who was previously appointed
chairman of Enron after its bankruptcy
stated in his declaration in support of
ftx's chapter 11 filing quote never in
my career have I seen such a complete
failure of corporate controls and such a
complete absence of trustworthy
financial information from compromise
systems integrity and faulty regulatory
oversight abroad to the concentration of
control in the hands of a very small
group of inexperienced unsophisticated
and potentially compromised individuals
this situation is unprecedented this
isn't a legal observation but that's
definitely not what you want to hear
from the guy that did the unwinding of
Enron so what else did we learn from
Rey's declaration well besides the fact
that FTX companies had poor to
non-existent corporate controls many of
them also gave out personal loans to
their owners bankman freed for example
got a one billion dollar loan from
Alameda research and some indications
estimate that the fair value of all the
crypto that FTX International holds is
less than a billion dollars far less
than bankman Freed's evaluation that
ftx's Holdings of ftt were worth at
least 5.5 billion the Declaration also
alleges that ftx's financial statements
don't include customer liabilities now
I'm not an expert in these things but I
don't think that meets Gap accounting
and if it seems like bankman freed and
his polycule members didn't know what
was going on that's probably because
quote the FTX group did not maintain
centralized control of its cash cash
management procedural failures included
the absence of an accurate list of bank
accounts and account signatories as well
as insufficient attention to the credit
worthiness of banking Partners around
the world I know it's hard to believe
but these crypto people might have made
some bad financial decisions now
furthermore Ray attests that quote in
the Bahamas I understand the corporate
funds of the FTX group were used to
purchase homes and other personal items
for employees and advisors and while Rey
has been pouring over the bankruptcy
financials bankman freed has spent a lot
of his time tweeting apologies for his
mistakes and giving interviews which is
not a great legal move there and one
interview was a text chain between uh
bankman freed and a fox reporter in
which he tells her that his public
beliefs in effective altruism were
basically just PR he said he didn't mean
to do unethical things but quote each
individual decision seemed fine and I
didn't realize how big their sum was
until the end and the end result is that
these f FTX companies are insolvent and
complicating things further there's the
second bankruptcy filed by the
bahamanian FTX company which claims to
be the primary bankruptcy filing for
chapter 15 bankruptcy and in finding
those jurisdictional claims the original
Delaware bankruptcy lawyers are claiming
that the government officials in the
Bahamas are engaging in all kinds of
corrupt acts and are basically colluding
with Sam bankman freed it's a giant mess
but bankruptcy isn't their only problem
the companies will have to deal with U.S
and foreign Regulators lawsuits from
consumers and even criminal enforcement
actions so there's little doubt that the
government is now investigating but
there are two U.S agencies that are
vying to regulate crypto and probably
this case in particular these Securities
and Exchange Commission the SEC and the
commodity Futures Trading commission or
cftc now crypto is a security then it
falls under the jurisdiction of the SEC
but if it's a commodity then the cftc
gets involved now the cftc has exclusive
jurisdiction over accounts agreements
and transactions involving swaps or
contracts of sale of a commodity for
future delivery the cftc has asserted
jurisdiction over fraud and manipulation
involving spot Market transactions
relating to Commodities which underlie
futures or swaps the cftc first
determined that Bitcoin and other
virtual currencies were properly defined
as Commodities back in 2015. and the
cftc ruled that people who had created a
platform for the purchase and sale of
Bitcoin options were actually operating
a facility for the trading or processing
of swaps without being registered as a
swap execution facility or designated
contract Market the cftc then initiated
enforcement actions Folk focusing on
classic cases of Fraud and Ponzi schemes
now courts are still deciding whether
digital tokens are securities or not
they do this according to the Howie test
which refers to the 1946 Supreme Court
case in which the Supreme Court set
forth a framework for deciding whether
an investment contract exists which
states quote there must be an investment
of money or other assets and a common
Enterprise with the expectation of
profit to be derived from the efforts of
others the absence of one prong will
prove fatal to a finding that an
investment is an investment contract and
the SEC recently stated quote the main
issue in analyzing a digital asset under
the Howie test is whether the purchaser
has a reasonable expectation of profits
or other Financial returns derived from
the efforts of others and while this is
certainly up in the air I think it's
likely that courts are going to say that
cryptocurrencies fall under the category
of Securities so FTX Executives could be
prosecuted under U.S Securities laws the
company may have violated the Securities
Exchange Act of 1934 rule 10 B which
makes it illegal to directly or
indirectly use any measure to fraud make
false statements omit relevant
information or otherwise conduct
business operations that would deceive
another person in the process of
conducting transactions involving stock
and other Securities and traditionally
violations of rule 10B have included
insider trading as well as defrauding
investors by hiding losses or low
Revenue with Creative Accounting
practices and that's not even including
the possible violations of myriad
different state laws for fraud or
misappropriation as well and although
FTX was headquartered in the Bahamas
eventually the company sold products to
American consumers so if you're raising
assets from American customers you're
placing yourself within the jurisdiction
of U.S laws and one of the main issues
that looks just super bad that's a legal
term is that FTX loaned customer money
to Alameda research it's reported that
customers did not know that FTX was
using their funds to make financially
risky trades when customers sought to
withdraw their money they discovered
that their funds were not available and
there's another interesting wrinkle to
the scheme which is that Alameda would
then buy up ftt tokens to prop up FTX
this makes the entire Enterprise look
more and more like a Ponzi scheme and
where both FTX and alimator were looking
out for each other but neither of them
were helping their investors though
potentially some of the liability here
will depend on the contracts with
customers and between the different
companies you can't disclaim fraud in a
contract but it's possible that some of
the customers might have affirmatively
agreed to some of this Behavior by
agreeing to the terms and conditions of
the exchange but does this mean that
company Executives could be charged with
crimes well let's start with the most
obvious one wire fraud wire fraud is a
type of fraud involving the use of
telecommunications or the internet why a
fraud could include any form of
electronic media including emails social
media text messages or even good
old-fashioned fax machines if the
defendant used Interstate telephone
calls or electronic communications then
the government can prosecute and under
18 USC 1343 there are four elements to
Classic wire fraud one that the
defendant voluntarily and intentionally
devised or participated in a scheme to
defraud another out of money two that
the defendant did so with the intent to
fraud three that it was reasonably
foreseeable that Interstate wire
Communications would be used and for the
interstate wire Communications were in
fact used So based on what we know could
bank and freed be prosecuted for wire
fraud well the doj probably faces two
large hurdles to prosecution the first
would be jurisdictional FTX and
Associated companies are Incorporated in
the Bahamas and up until recently most
Executives live there and they would
argue that the doj doesn't have
jurisdiction to prosecute them but
prosecutors could overcome this defense
if they can show that there is a Nexus
between FTX and the United States
prosecutors would say that FTX does lots
of business in America and as customers
in the US it uses American Banks its
Executives frequently travel to the U.S
and further into of the crypto business
and it's safe to assume that the doj
could probably clear that jurisdictional
hurdle now the second problem for the
doj is intent section 1343 requires
proof that the defendant acted with the
intent to defraud that is the intent to
deceive and cheat so if bankman free did
a bad job of managing the company that's
not a crime the government would have to
prove that he did it on purpose now
coinbase CEO Brian Armstrong said he
believed that bankman free did commit
fraud like like FTX coinbase is a crypto
exchange and Armstrong said that he
spoke with both Sam bankman freed and
binance CEO Chung Pung Zhao who briefly
considered buying FTX and during those
conversations Armstrong got the
impression that FTX knowingly and
improperly used customer funds to prop
up Alameda you know FTX was in a
position where they had this Market
maker Alameda that was investing in
Risky things and that's fine like market
makers hedge funds they're designed to
take more risk so it seems they had this
solvency issue and instead of just
letting it blow up Sam basically said
hey we have a bunch of customer assets
over here at FTX or he somehow basically
made a loan from FTX into Alameda to try
to prop it up I don't know why he did
that I mean that that's the moment in my
mind where he crossed the line into
probably committing fraud and I I think
he probably lied to users lied to
investors and he went around and tried
to bail out these different companies
like like Voyager and blockfy and to
sort of prop up this thing and maybe he
thought he'd could trade his way out of
it so FCX customers believe that their
crypto was immediately accessible but
according to Armstrong FTX used customer
assets to fund the operating expenses of
the company but fcx's terms of service
seem to clearly prohibit lending on
those assets it says quote none of the
digital Assets in your account are the
property of or shall or may be loaned to
FTX trading FTX trading does not
represent or treat digital assets in
users accounts as belonging to FTX
trading so the government will assess
all of bank and freed statements and the
actions to figure out if he was just in
over his head or whether he knew he was
defrauding customers John Ray accused
the companies of commingling assets
using company money for personal
projects and using software to hide
their moves from consumers all that goes
to bankman Freed's intended to commit
fraud so I asked former SEC prosecutor
Ron geffner about this whole situation
with regard to FTX there appear to be
many misrepresentations and acts of
fraud based on the facts that are
currently available the county it seems
to be most egregious or material
misrepresentations as to use of funds
and where the money was being sent into
where theoretically is being held on
behalf of consumers and investors it
would appear that corporate governance
at FTX was at the very least we can all
agree sloppy it may have risen to the
level where corporate governance was
fraudulent in the fact that there were
conflicts of interest there were
misrepresentations made to both the
public and to both private investors
public and private investors made
decisions based on false factual
information whether the principles of
FTX will be prosecuted criminally it's
going to depend on whether the U.S
justice system has standing in any case
against FTX given them much of their
behavior occurred offshore it is out of
my well house but
based on patterns I've seen
even if investors recover
any kind of enumeration or their assets
I have to imagine will be Pennies on the
dollar the takeaway I would have is
pessimism is a good thing no matter what
you're investing in it's why do I have
this opportunity what is the opportunity
what is the upside and what is the
downside risk and in many cases as human
beings when we assess what is the worst
case scenario we rarely ever really
assess what is worst case we usually
assess what's a bad case but not what is
the worst case and it goes back to if
you don't understand don't invest and if
you can't afford to lose it all then
theoretically don't invest in these
types of opportunities now that's not
the end of the story here because FTX
promoted itself and created an era of
legitimacy by associating with
celebrities like Tom Brady Gisele
Bundchen Shaquille O'Neal Larry David
and Naomi Osaka and those people have
now been sued by investors in a headline
grabbing class action lawsuit Edwin
Garrison is the name plaintiff who had
an FTX yield bearing account which he
funded with crypto assets to earn
interest now Sam bankman freed is the
lead defendant in this case but
investors are also suing those celebrity
promoters and Garrison alleges that
while FTX lured U.S investors to its
yield bearing accounts it was quote a
Ponzi scheme where investor funds were
shuffled into related entities to
maintain the appearance of liquidity and
while this lawsuit made headlines is
going to be a really uphill battle to
recover from the celebrity endorsers
plaintiffs allege that defendants
violated the Florida investors
protection act and the law extends
liability to any director officer
partner or agent of or for the seller if
the director officer partner or agent
has personally participated or aided in
making the sale but it's not clear that
a celebrity endorsement makes them an
agent of the seller for purposes of this
act it's also not clear that advertising
for the FTX exchange or even
theoretically its yield bearing accounts
qualifies as a security under the act
and as we discussed above it's unclear
whether crypto itself is a security but
advertising for the exchange rather than
a specific security adds yet another
level of abstraction for the celebrities
and similarly these lawsuits claims for
unfair Trade Practices which relies on
an underlying liability or civil
conspiracy which requires an agreement
would be extraordinarily hard to prove
against the celebrity endorsers though
one wrinkle here is that both Tom Brady
and Gisele Bundchen reported to have
taken a huge Equity stake in FTX which
actually might change the result what do
you think are you in you know what I'm
in now a lot of people want to know
whether FTX customers are going to see
any kind of recovery whether through
lawsuits or as unsecured creditors in
the bankruptcy process and chapter 11
has been around for forever and has a
solid process but unfortunately U.S
bankruptcy courts don't have much
experience handling bankruptcy claims of
crypto companies two crypto lending
companies Celsius and Voyager digital
filed for bankruptcy production earlier
this year and customer assets are still
frozen so it'll take lots of time
probably years to determine whether FTX
customers can recover anything and in
fact the mount gox bankruptcy is eight
years old and is still ongoing and the
fact that crypto is largely unregulated
means that customers aren't protected by
the same kinds of safeguards that exist
when Banks and other brokerage firms
fail now if you invested in FTX you'd
probably benefit from exclusive class I
made for nebula called how to sue like a
lawyer it's 90 minutes of information
and jokes about the legal system which
you'll need if you actually want to get
your money back from FTX and it's
available only on today's sponsor nebula
on nebula my videos come out early with
zero ads and I release exclusive content
all the time like an entire video about
legal stories that are not safe for work
and are too hot for YouTube which is
unfortunately too hot for YouTube my
first full-length documentary bad law
words good and two full-length classes
plus tons more all exclusive to nebula
and there's other amazing exclusive
content like jet lag the game which is
basically like The Amazing Race but for
creators and it's honestly my favorite
thing on the internet right now or if
you want to learn more about the FTX
situation you could watch cold fusions
videos on FTX ad free and on nebula you
get nebula First videos released way
early zero ads nebula originals and now
for the first time when you sign up for
nebula directly you get nebula classes
which is a 150 value nebula is Creator
owned and all the creators on the
platform share equity and we've been
developing nebula like crazy it now has
apps for iOS Android Apple TV Roku Fire
TV and Android TV now nebula is normally
50 a year but you can sign up directly
with the link that's on screen right now
or in the description it can get 20 off
that's forty dollars for the entire year
now with nebula classes it's the best
way to support legal eagle but what's
more signing up will actually help
countless independent educational
creators Beyond just legal eagle so sign
up now by clicking on the link that's on
screen right now or click on the link
that's down below in the description get
a huge discount for nebula and after
that click on this box over here for
more legal eagle or I'll see you in
court